je peux pas pardonner qu'on ait tué
Marie je ne pardonnerai jamais
est-ce que je peux vous poser une
question concernant Paul comment vous
avez réussi à le construire Paul Paul et
le et votre fils il est fils de Marie
Marie Trintignant vous avez vécu
plusieurs années avec avec sa maman
comment va-t-il
écrivain il écrit bien maintenant
écrivain c'est un drôle de parcours
comme je lui ai dit un mauvais écrivain
savant beaucoup et un bon écrivain ça va
pas beaucoup donc choisis bien lequel tu
veux être en sachant qu'un mauvais
écrivain ça n'apporte rien à soi-même et
c'est éloigné volontairement de la
France non non c'est simplement pour une
histoire d'amour qu'il est porté en
Australie mais il va revenir quand vous
dites comment bien sûr formidable la
meilleure mais quand vous dites comment
j'ai pu le construire je dirais que
c'était à lui de se construire vous
savez c'est une histoire entre
entre lui et sa maman c'est une histoire
terrible
je n'ai plus que l'essayer de le
protéger peut-être même trop parce que
j'ai eu très peur de sa réaction de la
violence de sa réaction et il était tout
petit quand sa mère a été tuée donc il
avait 10 ans donc j'ai essayé de le
couver de le de lui donner le plus
d'amour possible pour que il se retrouve
pas abandonné puisqu'il avait vécu avec
ses frères et Marie toute son enfance et
qui débarquait chez moi à ce moment-là
donc j'ai donné le plus de tendresse
possible j'ai essayé aussi d'être
exigeant par rapport à l'école parce que
ça ne voulait pas que ça s'enchaîne avec
un échec scolaire qui aurait pu vraiment
le déstabiliser ensuite c'est quelqu'un
qui a une très forte personnalité Paul
je crois que la violence de ce qu'il a
vécu j'espère qu'il pourra le mettre au
service de son art maintenant c'est pas
les meilleurs enfants ce qu'ils soient
vous avez pardonné vous-même non je ne
pardonne jamais
je ne pardonne pas aux gens qui frappent
les femmes qui les tuent comme je ne
pardonnerai pas aux assassins Dylan
halimiques de toujours pas digéré comme
je pardonne pas à ceux qu'humilie les
homosexuels comme je ne pardonne pas à
ceux qui se foutent de la gueule des
gros à ceux qui estiment que les Juifs
sont riches et à toute cette pagaille de
connard de stupides d'ignorants qui font
un mal fou et de parti politique qui
surf sur les anxiétés des gens et sur
leur ignorance je peux pas pardonner
qu'on ait tué Marie je ne pardonnerai
jamais
[Musique]